[Musica]
[Applauso]
fin da bambino ho avuto la passione per
le stelle per il cielo stellato di
capitava magari d'estate di stare
disteso su un prato guardando in alto le
costellazioni e pensavo allora che da
grande avrei voluto volare attraverso le
strade stelle e avrei comunque voluto
sapere tutto che cos'è erano come si
muovevano e così via
andando a scuola ho cominciato a
imparare i primi rudimenti della fisica
e la mia passione per il cielo e per
l'universo è diventata ancora attiva
intensa ha cominciato a nascere però
qualche come dire qualche dubbio
curiosità perché avevo la sensazione che
alcuni dei nostri comportamenti normali
e in qualche caso andassero in contrasto
con quelle leggi che stavano cominciando
a studiare questa percezione è diventata
più sostanziale più ragionata
col passar del tempo sono arrivato
all'università o quella conoscenza delle
tecnologie e così via e diciamo che il
forte impulso ad approfondire questi
ragionamenti mi è venuto quando ormai
ero laureato ho potuto leggere i limiti
dello sviluppo che era la pubblicazione
degli studi fatti da un gruppo delle
mighty per conto del club di roma che
attraverso delle grandi e complesse
simulazioni mostravano che andando
avanti come si era sempre andati fino a
quel momento per quanto riguardava
l'economia per esempio l'umanità avrebbe
incontrato dei seri guai e anche
relativamente relativamente presto a
questo punto diciamo cerchiamo di
entrare in argomento però cerchiamo di
capire meglio io a quelle epocali
procura il software che veniva usato le
mighty ormai aveva già entrato
politecnico di torino e cominciare a
fare dei modelli per conto mio molto più
semplici per vedere un po come
funzionavano queste simulazioni e così
via
allora entriamo in in argomento a questo
punto nel merito
diciamo che
se noi ci guardiamo intorno e se non
delle parole ricorrenti che meno usate
moltissimo specialmente oggi una di
queste parole sostenibilità è
l'aggettivo sostenibile viene usata un
po come un mantra se volete come una
formula esorcistica con una parola
magica per cui noi abbiamo certe cose
che abbiamo sempre fatto continuiamo a
farle però aggiungiamo un etichetta
sostenibile dobbiamo fare un grattacielo
nuovo da qualche parte sì sì sì
sostenibile dobbiamo fare un nuovo
raccordo autostradale certo portesi a
sostenibile una galleria sotto le
montagne si ma sostenibile e questo vale
per tutta la cantieristica più o meno
grande per la produzione industriale
così via
è una parola che serve a
tranquillizzarci se però ci fate caso
voi non credo che abbiate mai trovato
negli articoli che si leggono e così via
una definizione di sostenibile che cosa
voglia dire sostenibile cosa voglia dire
sostenibilità il termine deve
rassicurare restando più o meno vago
proviamo a ragionarci e andiamo più
vicino al tema per un'altra parola che
viene
frequentissimamente usata molto di più
che sostenibile sostenibilità oggi è la
parola crescità la crescita la sentite
sempre
quando sentite un discorso leggete
qualcosa di un economista la sentite
quando a parlare sono i rappresentanti
di confindustria la vedete in bocca ai
politici di tutte quasi tutte le parti
politiche maggioranze e opposizioni e
così via crescita la crescita deve
essere rilanciata non è abbastanza
vivace sta rallentando
dobbiamo sostenerla
se la crescita non procede sono guai
qualcosa non funziona ma stiamo parlando
della crescita di che cosa beh se vuoi
journal leggete appunto i giornali
ascoltati alla televisione alla crescita
e del prodotto nel vuoto interno lordo
del famoso pil
ho il sospetto che la maggior parte
delle persone non sappia bene che cosa
sia il pil in realtà però una cosa
l'hanno capita a tutti deve crescere se
non cresce sono sono dolori questo è il
punto centrale se però andiamo a
guardare un po da vicino vediamo che
questa benedetta crescita
invariabilmente è materiale in sostanza
la crescita e di cose di prodotti che
devono essere
fabbricati dentro degli stabilimenti per
essere fabbricati e prodotti hanno
bisogno di risorse primarie di materie
prime e appunto e di energia e noi
vogliamo che tutto ciò cresca di piu di
più di più sempre di più
ora non è che ci voglia una grande
cultura scientifica per capire che in
realtà in un ambiente finita limitato
come necessariamente il nostro nulla può
indefinitamente crescere nulla di
materiale cui indefinitamente crescere
tanto più oggi che non possiamo più
neanche appigliarsi appellarci alla lidi
del mondo quasi infinito che ormai con
la globalizzazione è evidente a tutti
che il mondo a noi accessibile è
limitato quindi c'è poco da fare
e allora allora questo problema della
crescita è un problema molto serio
dovremmo cambiare cambiare qualche cosa
evidentemente è però dovremo cambiare
qualche cosa
ci vediamo che cosa
se ragioniamo possiamo trovare che la
situazione è anche più
delicata di quanto abbiamo accennato
fino ad ora cioè un conto è
l'esaurimento delle risorse la loro
insufficienza e così via però ci sono
anche dei meccanismi che rappresentano
dei vincoli ancora più stretti di quelli
che ho appena citato e mi spiego se noi
dobbiamo produrre qualcosa degli oggetti
delle cose delle merci anche erogare dei
servizi abbiamo che nessuno stabilimento
il quale produce queste cose ho una
macchina che le produce ci sarà un
flusso di cose fabbricate in uscita e
naturalmente ci sarà anche un flusso in
entrata ci vogliono delle famose materie
prime ci vuole dell'energia se vogliamo
alimentare il flusso in uscita
ovviamente se noi vogliamo crescere il
flusso di beni che produciamo in uscita
e dovremo aumentare anche flusso in
entrata
quello che esce ciò che a noi interessa
quello che per noi vale quello che entra
ce la dobbiamo mettere se no il tutto
non funziona diciamo che il costo il
costo materiale di tutto questo nel
momento in cui noi a questo meccanismo
aggiungiamo la volontà di crescita
vogliamo avere un flusso crescente di
beni prodotti o di servizi erogati in
uscita ovviamente l'ho già detto
dobbiamo fare aumentare il flusso in
entrata
e fin qui va bene l'abbiamo capito però
c'è una sorpresa se guardiamo più da
vicino che quando il flusso in uscita da
un certo processo aumenta il flusso che
devo immettere in entrata aumenta sia
anche lui ma guarda caso aumentato in
fretta
facciamo un esempio molto semplice
supponete di essere su un automobile
siete su una strada dovete andare da
qualche parte e viaggiato a una certa
velocità volete arrivare prima e che
cosa fate aumentati alla velocità
proporzionalmente all'aumento di
velocità avrete una riduzione del tempo
il viaggio
naturalmente
comprensibile a tutti se io voglio
andare più forte velocità più alta
dovrò immettere dell'energia aumentare
l'energia del movimento del veicolo con
me a bordo soltanto che guarda un po
l'energia cinetica l'energia di
movimento di qualcosa non è
proporzionale alla velocità ma è
proporzionale al quadrato della velocità
cioè in parole povere in soldoni se io
raddoppio la velocità l'energia che devo
introdurre e quattro volte quella di
prima non solo il doppio allora se le
cose stanno così è un meccanismo di
crescita noi apprendiamo dei valori la
produzione che esce fuori a un certo
valore
il costo materiale e un costo appunto il
nostro vantaggio la differenza tra i due
ma se è vero che il costo materiale
cresce più in fretta il risultato è che
ebbe il vantaggio tende a essere in
qualche modo eroso abbiamo un andamento
nel tempo una curva in cui per un po il
vantaggio per noi aumenta sale e siamo
tutti contenti però a un certo punto si
raggiunge un massimo e poi e poi si
dovrà tornare giù come come vantaggio e
uno può anche pensare beh vediamo poi se
comincia a scendere faremo qualcosa poi
ci pensiamo no perché in realtà superato
il massimo nei che si scende di nuovo si
precipita si crolla il vantaggio per noi
crolla questo comportamento ci permette
di agganciarci a un'altra cosa su cui
riflettere noi singolarmente siamo parte
di un sistema complesso grandissimo le
costerà la biosfera all'interno delle
costiere ma cos'è un sistema complesso
non è semplicemente un sistema
complicato un sistema con tantissimi
elementi 1 siamo noi individualmente una
comune umanità questi elementi sono
tutti collegati fra loro hanno tutti dei
vincoli
interagiscono fra di loro
in concreto cosa significa questo che io
faccio qualcosa qui psicologicamente mi
aspetto di avere delle conseguenze qui
dove ho fatto quello che ho fatto qui e
ora
in realtà in un sistema complesso
invariabilmente avrò anche delle
conseguenze che si propagano molto più
lontano anche nel tempo il nostro
sistema complesso in cui siamo immersi
evolve un sistema dinamico
c'è una sorta di equilibrio dinamico che
procede dinamico cosa vuol dire un po
come andare in bicicletta non è che sei
stati crono è un equilibrio di nan
benissimo nelle condizioni come dire
ordinarie cui ci siamo abituati
rimane sempre vero questa storia delle
conseguenze che vanno molto lontane però
sono conseguenze che
sono minori rispetto a quelle locali per
cui se anche le trascuro non è un gran
problema in realtà però nei sistemi
complessi ci sono delle configurazioni
via corso cui si evolve che son dette
critiche
cosa sono le configurazioni critiche
sono quelle cose per cui procedendo
andando avanti
diciamo che l'equilibrio dinamico
diventa sempre più instabile arriviamo a
un punto in cui basta fare poco
pochissimo localmente e succedono
sconquasso concretamente il sistema
tutto intero si riorganizza si passa da
un certo equilibrio dinamico quello
precedente a uno molto diverso e in un
tempo molto breve è per l'appunto un
collasso o una catastrofe c'è una teoria
delle catastrofi licenza che seguì
queste cose è la logica del ponte
morandi se volete o della valanga che
toccate qualcosa viene giù tutto e
quindi è un problema molto serio questo
noi ci stiamo avvicinando a una
condizione del genere ci dicono i
climatologi se andiamo avanti come
stiamo andando avanti
e allora che fare ragionevolmente se
abbiamo capito dobbiamo cambiare
cambiare cosa cambiare no mettere
l'etichetta grino sostenibile dobbiamo
cambiare proprio i meccanismi del dare e
dell'avere del produrre e mettere le
briglie a questo concetto della crescita
il che però non è facile e oltretutto
implica anche modificare un po il
profilo sociale
ridurre i vantaggi di qualcuno rispetto
a qualcun altro e non ci piace allora
che facciamo noi beh se andiamo a dire
no prima non avevo niente ma oggi non si
può più dire non è vero niente si vede
intorno a noi che sta succedendo
qualcosa oppure possiamo dire a ma la
scienza sta progredendo risolverà tutto
la scienza non fa miracoli per
definizione e per di più una cosa che sa
con certezza mentre il futuro lo prevede
con un certo indeterminazione la cosa
che sappia con certezza quello che non
si può fare
e c'è poco da fare dovremmo cambiare le
cose che magari sono antipatiche da
cambiare però qui nasce un altro
problema che noi vabbè abbiamo capito ma
noi non siamo proprio del tutto
razionali ciascuno di noi è come se
avesse dentro due persone chiamiamole
dottor jekyll e mister hyde il dottor
jekyll e una persona colta ha studiato e
attenta a quello che succede a quello
che dice la scienza ragiona e individua
che cosa bisognerebbe fare
mister hyde che siamo sempre noi è
invece un soggetto rozzo ignorante
diffida di tutto e di tutti e
aggressivo perché ha paura di tutto e
vive racchiuso nel presente immediato e
nell'ambito circoscritto in cui si trova
il problema è che fino a oggi le
decisioni importanti tende a prenderle
continuare a prenderle sempre mister
hyde e non il dottor jekyll se noi
vogliamo fare qualcosa dobbiamo mettere
le briglie a mister ai tanto più che le
conseguenze di questo tracollo e sul
quale stiamo galoppando si saranno sulle
nostre spalle abbastanza presto ma il
quale che saranno soprattutto sulle
spalle di ragazzi ragazze bambini
bambine che ci stanno intorno in questo
momento e allora noi pensiamo di fare il
loro interesse pensare al loro futuro ma
in realtà andando avanti così stiamo
distruggendo il loro futuro dobbiamo a
questo punto metterci davanti ad uno
specchio e vedere ma io voglio essere
più jekyll hyde ci sono dei problemi era
in grande scala e problemi a piccola
scala ma io devo mettere il bavaglio a
mister hyde e far vincere il mio dottor
jekyll questo è quello che devo fare si
può fare beh sì siamo esseri razionali
quindi dovremmo essere in grado di farlo
naturalmente l'altra opzione è quella di
fare come abbiamo fatto sempre in
passato cioè in definitiva fa finta di
niente andare avanti se vogliamo
metterla sullo scherzo l'altra opzione è
ben espressa da una frase che venne
detta un secolo fa da un famoso comico
americano anni venti trenta del secolo
scorso che si chiamava guscio marx bene
coach a max ebbe a dire ma perché dovrei
preoccuparmi dei posteri cosa hanno mai
fatto i posteri per me e questo è la
lezione diciamo che ci dà la realtà
[Applauso]